♪～
こんにちは！ＧＯＤはじめしゃちょーです。
今日は～
ほかでもない
俺は 昨日の夜、
ローソンの中にある 全ドリンクを買った。
まあ…大迷惑だ。
まじで大迷惑だ。
深夜に行ったんで、お客さんも全然居なくてね、
暇そうだったんで、まあ よしとしましょう。
水という水を全部買ってきました。
別に万引きとか そんなことはしないからね。
ちゃんとこちらに証拠があります。
まじ万引きしてねえかんな！自腹でちゃんと買ったからな。
これは常連じゃないとできなかったですね。迷惑だし。
本当にありがとうございました。
という訳で、305点です。
Pontaポイントは1000ポイント貯まりました。ありがとうございます。
誰に馬鹿と言われても、もう自分でも馬鹿って分かってるからいいよ。
まあ、天才と馬鹿は紙一重だからさ。
まあ  お前らが馬鹿と言っても、俺は天才に近い人間だ。
これはマジでね、一度はやってみたかったんですけども、
日本中のドリンクを 全部集める っていうのは無理なんで、
なんでもそろっている、コンビニですね。
コンビニの 全ドリンクです。
もういろいろあるよ。 こういうなんか…あっ　これはよくない。
乳製品から 栄養剤とか、アルコール以外は全部買ってきました。
まあ 日本中のドリンクは無理なんで、
一個一個紹介していきたいんですけど、さすがに  しんどいんで、
無しです！
イェイ イェイ イェイ！（腹を叩く）
イェーイ！イェイ×10
(ラップ調) 俺の名前ははじめ　真面目　根は真面目　         いじめは嫌って　けじめ　必要
Yo Yo! Come on!Come on!
(ラップ調) 久しぶりの　めちゃくちゃ動画で　ちょっとテンション上がってる
Come on! Come on! イェイ イェイ！
(ボイスパーッカッション風) hey hey hey！Come on! Come on!
（歌）　どーやって　どーやって　飲むかは！（チッチッチッ）
（歌）どーやって　飲むかは？　どーやって　飲むかは？
そう！拓哉
（歌）全部飲むのは 難しいからっ
（歌）ストローで　一滴採って
（歌）この～　魔法の小瓶に～　全部入れるよ～！
（叫び声）
俺が　歴史を変える。
じゃあ いきまーす。
今年は多分、ここら辺のペットボトルだけでも生きていけるから、
もうジュースは 買うことないです。
こういう感じで…こういう感じで入れていきます。
（ジュースを飲む音）
超うめえ
♪～
よし…　はい、とりあえず 乳製品は終わりです。
乳製品は保存ができないから…
もったいねえな。ちょっと全部冷蔵庫に入れてきます。
はい乳製品しまり終わ…。　はい乳製品しまおい…あ
はい乳製品しま
はい、乳製品は終わったんで ここからは保存が効くものが多いんで、
パパッと入れましょう。
けっこう しんどいね
てか 300種類混ぜるって馬鹿でしょ…
でも多分 やった人がいないから、
その点俺はやっぱ 天才かもしんねえな。
♪～
これ 飲んでみたい
凄十（すごじゅう）…ちょっと飲んでみたいっすね。
ヴええ～　不味い 不味い 不味い
♪～
っしゃあ！　ラスト！！
やっと終わったよ～～
はい 終了で～す。
できましたあ～～
（笑い）エエア゛ァ～
約300種類、コンビニの全種類のドリンクを混ぜた、
名付けて、
です。
インフィニティコーヒーね、うん。
乳製品…（物を落とす）ああっ うー
乳製品が比較的多かったんで、どっちかっていうとコーヒー軸ですね。コーヒー軸です。
多分これがマジで 世界で一番、いろんなものを含んでます。
いい意味でも、悪い意味でも。
♪～
君たち、やっとできたよ。　夢のドリンクが。
飲みたいかい？
（チッチッチッ）ごめんな、
動画じゃ 飲ませられないんだ。
という訳で！　俺が、身をもって
このインフィニティコーヒーの レビューをしようと思う。
まずはニオイから失礼します。
ウエ゛エ゛ェ…
あれ　ちょっと思ったのと違うな…
なんか、災いの臭いがします。
ベースはねえ、何だろう。訳分かんないんだよな
オロ、オロナミンＣ を土台となってます。
後から続いて、オレンジピール
後のピーチというか、セイロンティーというか、
アッサム地方からの ダージリンティーな雰囲気も醸し出しつつ、
臭いです。
インフィニティコーヒーだもん。
おいしいよ。
ああ…やばいな、いろんなもん入ってるからな
いろんなもん ってレベルじゃないからな。全部入ってるからな。
いや、死なないよ…死なないよ、少ないもん！
♪～
全部の味がします、マジで。
いや、これ逆にすごいよ。だって偏ってない。
入れた300種類の ジュースとかコーヒーとか牛乳とかを、
均等に体に流し込む感じです。
すべての成分を均等に受け取っている感じ。
あんまり不味くないです…いや不味いけどね、
不味いけどそんな…オエッて感じじゃなくて、
何、なんか 俺の体が受け付けねえのかな…
♪～
（インフィニティコーヒーを飲む音）
ウガッ…
（嘔吐）オエエエエエ
今日は早めに寝るよ
（エンディングテーマ）
アルコールが入ってないからね、君たち誰でもできるから、ぜひ！
ぜひ じゃねえわ。　やらないようにしましょう。